we are told that figure two is a scaled
copy of figure one and we can verify
that by comparing corresponding sides
corresponding sides or sides that have
the same relative position the same
they're playing the same role in each of
the diagrams even if the diagrams are
scaled versions of each other even if
they are different sizes so for example
if we were to compare
segment ea right over here it looks like
it corresponds to segment op
and the length of ea is three the length
of op is one two three four five six
and so for this to be a scaled copy the
scaling factor from what from the
corresponding side in figure 1 to the
corresponding side in figure 2 should be
a factor of 2 so it's times 2 right over
there
but let's just answer their questions
that they're asking us and then we can
also verify that it is a scaled copy
what point on figure one corresponds to
point q on figure two
all right pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
all right so point q on figure two is
right over there so what point on figure
one corresponds to that
well it would have it would be playing
the same role it would be in the same
relative position and so it looks like
this point right over here point b is in
that same relative position so point b
corresponds to point q on figure two
identify the side of figure two that
corresponds to segment dc in figure one
pause this video again and see if you
can figure that out
all right so segment dc and figure one
that is that right over there
and your eye might immediately catch
that hey the segment that's playing the
same role in figure two is this one
right over here and so that is segment
n
m put the line over it to make sure that
i'm specifying the segment and we can
once again verify the scale factor to
ensure that this is a scaled copy
for these two to correspond to each
other and for these to be scaled copies
of each other
dc has a length of one two three four
and nm has a length of one two three
four five six seven eight
so once again we are verifying that our
scale factor is two